what was it about
Clifford McBride that that you wanted to
play what was it about this character
that jumped out at you I'm a
science-fiction fan I have been since
childhood and fascinated with the story
impressed with James gray and and and
with Brad Pitt I thought that we had a
chance to put some good moments together
in a movie where some of your favorite
science fiction stories growing up were
you more of a Ray Bradbury fan Robert
Heinlein you know I read all of all
those guys nine years old and finally as
I look back I mean I've been pressed by
a book called the cat that walks through
walls what I never heard of that one
what's what's the what's that one about
it's about a 200 year old sex addict I
was curious
do you ever revisit the films that
you've acted in or directed in or do you
just sort of put them behind
I usually don't sometimes late at night
surf television and on most day is one
of mine will come up the later in the
evening that more likely it'll be and
I'll watch a few minutes of something I
did a few years ago but hell I was there
right don't need to watch it again no I
don't I don't revisit my own films it's
usually remorseful endeavor I usually
think about what I should have done if
I'm looking at a movie that I've
directed I usually think damn I wish I
hadn't cut that scene so you
I usually just it's for me it's an
experience of rethinking everything
everything but the reason I bring it up
is because three burials of Melquiades
Estrada was one of my favorite films of
2005 and I think that film is a long
time ago yeah but I just I feel like
it's even more powerful today because
what we're dealing with the immigration
sort of things along the border and I
just you know if you had any thoughts on
thinking back on that film or the
experience of making it you know I loved
making that film and I did it on purpose
and I believed every word of it you know
um you know you've been in this business
for a long time I was sort of curious
what are some of the big changes you've
sort of seen in your time some things
that are just really jump out of you it
the way the business has changed and in
the business of making movies I'd say oh
probably the transition from film to
[Music]
high-definition video does that sort of
give you more room as an actor since
you're not worried about running out of
film that you can try out different
things with different or is it just sort
of the lenses the look of the film the
lenses and and the look and and
management of light are different in
both of those they come on the last film
I did I used both the high-definition
cameras in north central New Mexico will
go blind around 10:30 or 11:00 o'clock
light is intense coming down directly
from above and they just don't see that
well the the film cameras will
understand everything in those
conditions when the Sun starts going
down or you get inside a cave or a house
the film cameras have problems at the
high definition cameras don't can
actually see better than
you can well thank you so much for
talking with me today I really
appreciate yes sir thank you